la cathédrale est un livre d'histoire
qui s'ouvre dès le parvis une flèche et
romane l'autre gothique flamboyantes les
vitraux familiarise les enfants avec la
religion chrétienne
un vitrail celui comme une bande
dessinée vous avez 25 30 scènes qui vont
vous accompagner vous raconter tout ce
qui arrive aux héros du vitrail est donc
souvent 1st parfois jésus et donc l'idée
de ces visites c'est aussi à la prendre
par la main de façon un peu plus ludique
de façon un peu plus interactive pour
que précisément ils comprennent
l'histoire qui est en train de se passer
les enfants et capte très très bien les
images et je dirais même que les capte
bien souvent plus vite que les adultes
ils sont beaucoup moins compliqué que
nous les enfants apprennent ainsi
pendant leurs vacances
hier des scènes qui sont représentées
dans les vitraux que j'ai pu comprendre
on voit comment ils éveillent avec les
dessins on voit à peu près comment il
était habillé ce qui faisait si un peu
une maison une grande maison de vos
retours importe c'est qu'ils sont
chrétiens
une étude a calculé que 400 heures sont
nécessaires pour une visite exhaustive
de l'édifice les jeunes devront revenir